well Merry Christmas everybody hey you
know I've been thinking during the
Christmas season about gratitude being
grateful it's kind of one of my new
themes these days grateful is attractive
we've talked about that before when
people are a grateful one it's a
character quality of theirs they're
highly attractive they say thank you and
they smile and they realize a sense of
humility that it's not all about them
that they didn't get to where they are
by themselves that their life is not the
sole result of their personal
intelligence or effort or Talent
when people are grateful there's always
a byproduct anytime someone is grateful
I'll tell you what you always see I
don't think there's ever an exception
grateful people are 100 percent of the
time
generous people they're generous always
generosity follows gratitude and I'm
grateful for the life that I have I'm
grateful for my wife Sharon I'm grateful
for my kids who are incredible young
adults I'm grateful for healthy
grandbabies let me tell you what else
I'm grateful for I'm grateful for an
incredible team that helps us with the
ministry that we have helping people all
over this nation and literally all over
this world
because I'm so grateful to that team I
can't help but be generous to that team
now it's not just me my whole leadership
team it's the generosity the gratitude
towards the people that do the work on
our team it's a part of the DNA of our
organization so I'm on the way right now
to do the coolest thing maybe that we've
ever done no we've done a lot of cool
things for our team members and we're
generous with bonuses and profit sharing
and all these different ways we're
generous with them to say that that
we're grateful for them but our
Christmas party this year was this
weekend and I'm on my way right now to
deliver the present with my leadership
team to our team members here's what we
did we went to Best Buy and said hey
guys if we bring all 400 of our team
members down there will you guys open
early bring in extra vendors extra stock
and give extra special discounts and put
stuff on sale just for this so we have a
private exclusive two hours shopping
extravaganza at Best Buy that's not open
to the public special deals just for our
team and get this when they walk up
they're gonna get a $1,000 gift card to
buy stuff in Best Buy I mean 400 of them
are getting a thousand dollar gift card
and we've got two hours off we took our
staff meeting off our staff meeting is
at Best Buy this morning so I'm on my
way down there right now and I'm gonna
take this camera in with us we're gonna
get some shots of this and you guys are
gonna get to participate in this and see
what generosity flowing out of gratitude
really looks like am i calling myself
holy and generous no don't misunderstand
me our guys work their tails off man
they and they are very smart and they're
very talented and they do it for all the
right reasons so this is fun these are
people I like I like working with them
every day and I'm so proud of them I'm
so grateful for them so watch this
you're gonna have fun with
I'm pulling up a test by their parking
lot is more cool than it has ever been
looked up
oh my gosh goodwill you're an elf that's
perfect I love it
what'd you get fine that's fun that's
cool cool what'd you get Cristina I got
a TV now I'm getting
what you get with Oh TV big TV rocket I
love it
Merry Christmas cool what you get David
Merrick respond fun what if like talking
gab
we got the Bose Soundlink Wireless for
the mouse and video games and movies for
the kids all right
Merry Christmas cute so what'd you guys
get TV time this is the TV line alright
there's more television action over here
another TV buyer oh so the TV counters
uh pretty popular but check out the
Appleton hour
they're lined up hey guys check it out